after more than a week of massive
protests the human tide showed no sign
of abating it was curry lambs second
back step in as many days on Sunday a
day after she promised to suspend the
extradition bill hundreds of thousands
of people clogged the streets of central
Hong Kong to demand that she removed the
bill permanently and that she steps down
they began to gather early on Sunday
morning umbrellas a symbol of their
pro-democracy desires as much as
protection from the Blazing Sun by
evening the streets of downtown Hong
Kong were packed that Carrie Lam had
taken one step back wasn't enough the
people demanded an apology and
eventually they got one she apologized
for the way her administration tried to
pass the China extradition law saying
she had misjudged the public mood she
admitted that the law had led to
conflict and distress but still Hong
Kong's people don't feel lamb went far
enough although we are united as one
we've got more than a million people
going on street this is a very saddening
time so but it's good that we can see
people getting United and then they all
stand together as one public anger still
seeds following violent clashes on
Wednesday when police used tear gas
rubber bullets and beanbag rounds to
disperse tens of thousands of protesters
so you gotta be super guilty though we
must teach the children that sell right
from wrong Hong Kong students came out
peacefully to express their opinions
even though they were a little impulsive
the police should not use rubber bullets
tear gas and bean bag round is hard to
deal with students on it over the whole
Sangha now it appears that nothing short
of Kari lambs resignation will make the
people back down
we're some analysis I'm joined now by
Bernhard Barch he's a senior Chinese
expert at the Bertelsmann Institute here
in Berlin thanks so much for being on
our program so many people have been
comparing these current protests in Hong
Kong to the umbrella movement five years
ago back then protesters they occupied
major streets in Hong Kong there trying
to get a greater say in the political
process but we know of course that those
efforts failed so how likely is it that
this time the protesters can succeed on
first sight it looks like they succeeded
because Carrie Lam actually did postpone
the extradition law and she did
apologize she apologized a bit at least
but the question is going to be whether
that is going to be a long-term success
and I'm very skeptical there because the
big game that is being played is that
the Beijing government that the
Communist Party of China is trying to
get Hong Kong under its control and
there's no way that Beijing is going to
stop these efforts I think they're
actually even going to increase them
because the one thing that Beijing does
not accept is a challenge to its
authority and this protest this
unprecedented protest of this size this
is so much bigger than the 2014 umbrella
movement protests this is something that
actually scares the Beijing government
and they don't want to see any of that
to get so they're going to get very very
tight fisted and I think we're going to
have a very tragic aftermath of this so
should Hong Kongers basically prepare
themselves for the inevitability that
their independence and their autonomy
from mainland China is basically on the
verge of being eliminated this protest
shows that people in Hong Kong are very
much afraid of exactly that and nobody
expected them to turn out in such huge
numbers it shows that they're really
concerned about this happening
and a lot of the rhetoric of the protest
has been that we have to defend our
autonomy what's left of it now because
if we don't do it now it's going to be
gone forever well the leader of Hong
Kong Carrie Lam she was saying this is
really about a lack of communication or
that an explanation what this
extradition bill is really about has
there been any specific statement than
from Beijing about what's going on
no Beijing has been very quiet publicly
the whole events in Hong Kong are more
or less censored in mainland China all
that they have been reporting is a
little bit about a riot in Hong Kong but
we must absolutely expect them to
internally send very very strong
messages to Hong Kong how they want this
handled basically from their point of
view Carrie Lam had one job to do and
that was to keep Hong Kong stable and to
not have any protests and she failed
majorly in this one big task that she
had from Beijing so she is going to get
a lot of heat from the central
government all right be on had barge
senior Chinese expert at the bertelsmann
Institute here in Berlin we thank you
very much for your insights thank you